we've been talking about some of the
younger members of the royal family well
they're going to be taking on larger
roles prince william and his wife kate
have been given additional titles
becoming the prince and princess of
wales and the duke and duchess of
cornwall the 40 year olds and their
family will take center stage as they
support king charles prince harry's
family has also stepped back into the
spotlight here in the uk in public
family events in king charles first
public address since ascending the
throne he spoke about his heir william
and also expressed his love for his
younger son harry and megan it was a
nice touch that many people noticed here
i'm here to discuss what's next for the
royal brothers is roy anika she is royal
editor of the sunday times and a cbs
news contributor roya so good to see you
and you come here this morning with some
breaking news
about the royal family tell us what
you've learned
well that's right we've just heard
recently in the last few minutes from
buckingham palace the king has made a
really important and significant
decision about what everyone is going to
wear for the next few days in terms of
all the processions we're going to see
up in scotland today with her majesty
the queen her coffin and later on here
um this week
we're told that only working members of
the royal family
will be wearing military uniform in
those processions and at those moments
except one interesting moment prince
andrew at that final vigil of the
queen's children four of them standing
at the four sides of her coffin he will
be allowed to wear military uniform just
once as a mark of respect to the queen
but what that also means is that it's
very unlikely that we will see prince
harry in military uniform the rest of
the family who are working members will
be in uniform harry will be in a suit
and that's where you will really start
to see the difference you know very
publicly in terms of who's a working
role and who's not and remember for
prince philip's funeral the queen made
the decision everyone should wear suits
everyone's on a laying plane level
playing field this is different but who
does this decision come from this edict
come from it comes from the king right
it comes from the kingdom it's a
decision that the king has taken well
why would they do that i mean then the
press here and the tabloid press will
make this big deal about prince harry
being in a suit but he made his own
decision to step back from royal duties
i think the view that the king has taken
is that there is a difference between
the funeral of the consort prince philip
and a state occasion this is the first
state funeral of harmonix since 1952
this is massive and so he wants to get
everything absolutely technically right
and it's only technically right that
only working members of the royal family
wear military uniform harry is no longer
a working member of the royal family but
that will be painful to him because of
course he served in afghanistan he
served he has done an enormous amount of
military duty 10 years of service
i want to bring in gail king who i know
will have additional questions on the
scale
i do roy roy anika it's good to see you
and you're right i think that will be
very painful to harry you know the other
day when king charles extended
when he expressed love for megan and
harry many people are speculating that
he was extending an olive branch i know
you've covered the royals for years
you've gotten to know them
so based on what you know did you see it
as an olive branch as well
well good morning gail i have to say i
have seen the last few days as nothing
but olive branches from the new king and
indeed the new prince of wales it was
really significant as you say that he
mentioned harry and megan in that
address
the next day when he signed his
proclamations at the accession council
he was using a silver ink pot that
william and harry had jointly given to
him these are really important symbols
and of course we know you know he is
he's going out of his way to make sure
they're included
that that moment from william reaching
out to harry as well on saturday saying
please come and come with us to windsor
and let's see do this walk about
together these are all really important
olive branches that are being extended
to harry and megan and they're being
welcomed which is crucial as well
he's also talked about slimming down the
royal family the working royal family
what does that look like what exactly
does that mean
do you know i think that's really
interesting i think we have seen that
shedding of members of the royal family
just by sort of natural wastage almost
in the last couple of years harry and
megan have stepped back andrew has
stepped back but i think going forwards
when you talk about the streamlined
monarchy it's just what nora was talking
about the weight of responsibility on
william and kate now be enormous you
know the focus over the next few days is
going to be this is the future it's very
tight it's william kate and and and
charles siblings and that's it
all right we have to go roy but i did
have one question about him being called
the prince of wales why was that
necessary what does that mean that now
charles that now william and kate are
the prince and princess of wales
you know what it wasn't naturally
automatically going to happen that was
decision from the king i think it's
really important that it shows that
william is following in the footsteps of
his father and it's it's a sign here
recognition of his seniority that he is
a heartbeat away from being king that's
what that title means
all right roy anika i knew you would
have the information we thank you we
thank you norah always good to see you
thanks a lot